pour l'heure dans gagnons nos chevaliers
de la formation à cannes
henri grandissent jean françois téaldi
bonsoir merci
et
mais
vous
exclu
premier hic la drire ce matin pour les
extravagantes pantomine de woody allen
dans un film pourtant quelconque
broadway danny rose mais soupe à la
grimace pour les journalistes le comique
américain avait boudé la conférence de
presse d'après projection
bonsoir si le grand week-end du festival
qui commence c'est ce soir il est signé
woody allen avec bredouille des névroses
que vous venez de voir signer aussi
wonder ce avec un film qui a obtenu un
succès son succès ce matin paris texas
et puis de l'autre côté de la croisette
à la quinzaine des réalisateurs s'est
dit herben de l'autrichien banane
à court terme il est à mener une enquête
de plusieurs mois infiltrant et des
couvrant plus de 180 organisations
paramilitaires néo nazis
camara pécresse
ont soutenu les jeunes de 14 à 20 ans
qui forment ces mouvements la plupart
sont au chômage sont issus de familles à
problèmes
les leaders de ces organisations sont de
vieux nazis rester fidèle à cette
idéologie l'histoire s'appuie donc sur
la réalité des faits de même que les
motivations du réalisateur c'était en
nous étions assis avec mon épouse dans
un petit restaurant lorsque tout à coup
entrèrent une vingtaine de jeunes gens
qui se mirent à battre les personnes
passent les clients de cette auberge et
moi même d'ailleurs telle manière que la
majorité d'entre nous dû être transporté
à l'hôpital
les jeunes néonazis chantait des
chansons et mettez des affiches au mur
dehors les étrangers le danger vient de
gauche ce n'est qu'à la fin du film que
nous avons commencé à recevoir les
premières menaces et une semaine après
sa sortie
nous avons eu des menaces de bombay
d'actions par téléphone contre moi et ma
famille s'il est un homme qui veut
parler de cannes c'est bien françois
chalais en toute modestie nous a dit
maintenant j'ai tout dit sur cannes
pourtant son témoignage est important la
vue qu'il a du festival est important à
travers toutes les rencontres qu'il a
fait alors je vous propose d'écouter un
pro françois chalais et puis une figure
aguigui mouna lorsque je faisais quand
vision y avait une seule télévision
c'était la mienne pour fait quand même
beaucoup plus commode ya des canaux miss
expressen la prenne au sérieux
c'était de grands journaux qui compte 1
et nous n'arrivons parent pauvre il
fallait presser kidnapper les gens hyper
fin danse du scalp ou celle de la
séduction
maintenant il faut parler du lait qui
n'a même et futurs du sikkim oui
maintenant et ailleurs ils ont un espèce
de planning c'est plus difficile
je sais par exemple que monkey souvient
d'importants ici vous avez robert de
niro vous allez voir ce que ça va être
déjà sur les marches du palais passe
privant pas de niro il a un avantage
c'est que il est méconnaissable à
volonté vous reverrez jamais il est
peut-être la côte et nous on sait pas
qui c'est dans le film de sergio leone
et l iphone un mec qu'il soit dit en
passant est un vrai chef d'oeuvre et vue
ah ouais j'ai vu à par olic c'est
l'événement du festival pour moi c'est
pas soyons les festivals c'est un très
grand événement de cinéma c'est un
événement qui reste risque d'être
éphémère puisque c'est que les
américains veulent en coupe et wej a
coupé beaucoup aussi exactement à
présenter couper ici et maintenant on va
où elle croyait une première coupure
mais fait quand même trois ans 40
il faudrait dire brothers il faudrait
que nous vaut des charlots il faudrait
que les gens qui nous fasse marrer alors
maintenant le sang le sang le santonnier
pour regarder alors que ses coaches
cause du voile à compresseur comme kill
and on voulait dire tenue table dans le
film français d'aujourd'hui alors que le
plein en place sans peine au cul là le
plein au cul le plein comme fait rire au
cul mais y'en a marre non je chasse et
limite le monde a besoin d'amour il peut
pas que tout pour faire un monde
il faut du bonheur et rien d'autre il
est certain que ce festival et des
répercussions dans la vie cannoise un
peu dans tous les domaines que ce soit
chez l'épicier ou celle hôtelier mais
aussi chez les enfants en témoignage ce
reportage qui a été fait dans une école
primaire jean pierre lamoureux qui a
déjà vu des vedettes lors du festival du
film cette année ou l'an dernier j'ai vu
dire il est oui ce au festival et
au carlton gérard des fêtes gérard
depardieu
moi j'ai vu gérard des peintures mais
j'étais très déçu parce que à la télé
les plus jeunes et plus vos que
confrères dans les aventures qu'est ce
qui vous passionne le plus bas par
exemple aussi à monsieur qui vont de sur
un pont et puis on donc qui est prêt à
craquer en demande aussi va tomber aussi
va pas tomber dans la cascade client qui
se trouve en bas d'un film qui me fait
rire c'est pas marché c'est pas moi
c'est lui avec quelques matches pour un
film d'horreur comme en empruntant
comment on plante un couteau dans le
ventre et qui ressort autre côté dans un
esprit de quelques chansons de michael
jackson
il est avec une fille au cinéma et il se
transforme en tout cas où on voit
pousser des moustaches 2 ou comment ils
ont failli se transformer un an tigres
royaux ont coupé le fil et et il se
transformer et apprendront leur on était
infime on peut dire qu'on aimerait être
actrice
voilà il me reste à vous dire bonsoir
bonne soirée bon dimanche à lundi au
revoir
oui
et